[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je veux dire, je suis assez dévasté évidemment de
perdre la finale de la Coupe du Monde, mais vous savez,
je pense que nous avons de quoi être fiers  et et
nous retournons dans un pays
qui est extrêmement fier de nous et vous
savez que cela signifie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
avant les jeux, je veux dire le choix de
sortir et de dire que j'étais gay et je
ne peux pas exactement mettre mon  le doigt dessus, mais je
pense que c'était la meilleure décision que j'aie jamais
prise, je me sentais très libre de me diriger vers
Londres et je pense que je joue de mon mieux et de
mon meilleur genou quand je fais ça
après cette Coupe du monde, nous espérons que la
ligue est  plus stable qu'il ne l'était avant,
nous espérons que l'état du
football féminin est plus grand et meilleur qu'il ne l'
était auparavant en termes de
performances des équipes et de
dollars de marketing et de télévision, vous connaissez les droits et ainsi de
suite
[Musique]
nous avons besoin  faire plus pour rendre les
espaces sportifs sûrs pour vous LGBTQ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
Parfois, le sport féminin est comme
le démarrage, donc les œuvres d'art et les budgets sont
si serrés que vous ne pouvez pas vous attendre à avoir une
entreprise
comme augmenter  votre budget comme vous le savez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]